netflix's latest star-studded drama the
trial of the chicago 7
written and directed by aaron sorkin
depicts the true story of eight
activists falsely accused of inciting
riots during the 1968 democratic
national convention now you might be
wondering to yourself
if there were eight on trial why isn't
it called the trial of the chicago eight
well i'll be covering all that and more
including the real-life characters
portrayed on screen
and also looking into whether some of
these events depicted in the film
actually happened like did abby and
jerry actually dress up as the judge and
wear police outfits under their gowns
but before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe so
you're notified as soon as one of my
videos comes out the film starts with
archival footage setting the stage for
the events to follow
mlk and bobby kennedy have been
assassinated the u.s is at war in
vietnam
and political and social unrest have
spread across the country the importance
of this context is highlighted by sasha
baron cohen's character abby hoffman
later in the film when justifying fellow
accused tom hayden
you can do anything to anything by
taking it out of context mr schultz this
trial doesn't make much sense without
framing it within the context of a
united states at war
divided and on the brink of social
change that's why sorkin begins the film
with actual footage to properly prime
the audience
and the parallels to modern day are
obvious as protests rage across the
streets
police engage in brutality and the
social political climate is at a tipping
point in fact the first draft of this
movie was written by sorkin in 2007
after steven spielberg approached him
about doing a movie on it but with both
men focused on
other projects it sat dormant for almost
a decade until the 2016 presidential
election
the resulting change spurred sorkin to
revisit the script and ultimately
directed himself
the first few minutes also set the stage
of the protests themselves
the democratic national convention was
in town and was a party divided you may
recall that the president at the time
was democrat lyndon b
johnson having been sworn into power on
november 22
1963 two hours after the assassination
of john f
kennedy seeing as he was the vice
president with a split democratic party
an increasing animosity for the war in
vietnam
he shocked the nation by announcing he
wouldn't run for re-election
and i will not accept the nomination of
my party for another term
as your president this pitted current
vice president hubert humphrey the
pro-war candidate against senator eugene
mccarthy who was anti-war
so thousands of protesters descended
upon chicago to protest the dnc's
nomination of a candidate who would be
just as pro-war as the republican
nominee richard nixon
there is simply not enough of a
difference between hubert humphrey and
richard nixon to make a difference
and so we're going to chicago these
protesters came from varying groups like
bobby seal head of the black panthers
who protested against an unjust war
sending thousands of african americans
to their death
tom hayden and reni davis who organized
students who saw their colleagues shift
off to war
david dellinger a pacifist who ran the
mobilization to end the war in vietnam
jerry rubin and abby hoffman leader of
the youth international party
also known as the yippies and finally
lee weiner and jon freund both
professors charged for their involvement
organizing the demonstrations the trial
would never have occurred if it weren't
for the transition of power from
democrat to republican
which saw former attorney general ramsey
clark appointed by jfk
replaced by john mitchell appointed by
president nixon fun fact john mitchell
was later found to be involved in the
watergate scandal
jon calls in u.s district attorney
richard schultz to invoke the rap
brown law a law originally passed by
southern whites
to limit the free speech of black
activists the law forbids conspiracy to
cross state lines to incite violence
schultz is caught off guard by this
request since former ag clark had the
fbi investigate the riots and found out
that it was actually the police who
instigated the violence but john
mitchell under the direction of
president nixon
wanted to show the nation that there
would be consequences for these protests
and the chicago seven would be tried for
their alleged crimes
schultz however sees this as a bad
decision as it would only give them a
bigger platform to spread their anti-war
agenda on top of everything else we're
giving them exactly what they want a
stage and an audience
for the state to successfully convict
they would have to prove these men
from varying groups and having different
political motivations
conspire together to incite violence and
the prosecution was
ruthless in its tactics including bobby
seal in the group
the head of the black panthers and
wanted for murder in connecticut a
murder he would later be found innocent
of
and speaking frankly the u.s attorney
wanted the negro defendant to scare the
jury i was thrown in
to make the group look scarier also the
scene where he was bound and gagged
actually happened and it didn't just
happen for one day it happened for
several
you can see a courtroom drawing
depicting this and this resulted in
defense lawyer william kunsler calling
the judge's courtroom quote a
medieval torture chamber bobby was
continually denied
access to his lawyer and later he'd be
given a mistrial leaving
seven to be tried and not eight john
mitchell's decision to indict these
members was also a personal one his
predecessor ramsay clark had apparently
resigned an
hour before mitchell's confirmation a
sign of disrespect so this was
mitchell's way of getting back at him
and why ramsay clark played by michael
keaton was so eager to take this stand
the jury never got to hear his testimony
however as the judge invoked voir dire a
separate hearing within the trial in
which the judge can determine whether
evidence is admissible not only that he
denied the defense's appeal to have the
jury notified that the former attorney
general was
questioned in the first place as the
film shows at the end 78
of chicago's attorneys had an
unfavorable opinion of judge
julius hoffman and they responded
overwhelmingly negative when asked if he
displayed an impartial attitude and
courtesy to both the prosecution and
defense
because the trial was deemed a farce
abby hoffman and jerry rubin would often
retaliate in kind
showing up one day in judges gowns with
police uniforms underneath not depicted
in the film was how abby would
continually call the judge
julie and one day he even brought in a
viet cong
flag which had to be wrestled out of his
hand all in all the defendants including
the lawyers received 170 citations of
contempt
ranging in prison time from two and a
half for winer
and four years and 18 days to lead
defense attorney william kunsler
these citations would later be thrown
out in the court of appeals as were the
prison sentences of the five
ultimately convicted of inciting
violence with weiner and throne being
acquitted the film also speaks to the
fractured nature of the democratic party
and one could argue how that party is
still fractured today
with progressives and neo-liberals
constantly at odds
there's no better encapsulation of this
than when tom and abby are trapped
against an upscale bar
as the rich democratic establishment
watches the convention
oblivious to the men and women
protesting outside to further hammer
home this point sorkin includes one
party member saying
am i the only one who sees what's going
on out there but even within this
progressive movement there are fractures
tom talks about how abby and the yippie
movement do a disservice to their cause
they aren't going to win over hearts and
minds by giving out flowers and
levitating the pentagon they need to be
taken
seriously and this seriousness and
respect for authority to a government
which looks at them with contempt
is something his character has to
overcome we see him stand up when the
judge leaves while the other accused do
not
at the end the judge tells him how
courteous and respectful he's been
during this whole process
and if his closing speech is brief and
well-mannered he'll take that into
account when delivering his sentence tom
needs to find the courage in himself to
stand up to a court and country which
has not shown him any respect
courage like he asked ramsay clark to
show in taking the stand
sir you have to find some courage now
he'll instead list off the names of the
over 4 700 american soldiers killed in
vietnam since the trial began five
months ago in protest of this sham
something even richard schultz stands up
for however the extent of his empathy
for the defense is something dramatized
by sorkin all in all the trial of the
chicago 7
shines a light on some of the political
issues we still face today
it's a scathing portrayal of the
criminal justice system and the
consolidation of power within political
parties the film asks us
how far are you willing to go to fight
for what you believe in
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and share as i'm
always coming out with new videos
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much